bien à l'abri des cryptomérias les
termes irénée accot de cilaos attire les
curistes de toute la réunion est de bien
plus loin encore ici on soigne ses
rhumatismes ou ses problèmes digestifs
mais l'établissement est surtout le
symbole de cette station de montagne
irénée accot y est il pour quelque chose
merci à ce premier vers cilaos
conseiller général aussi depuis 1963 10
15 milles jusqu'à la mort 1990 il y
avait beaucoup d'entreprises et a fait
beaucoup mais bien une station thème les
préconisations du stade les routes
asphaltées tous il avait
son image d'aujourd'hui cilaos la doit
en grande partie à irénée accot
ce dionysien né en octobre 1909 doit se
mettre à l'ouvragé dès 13 ans pour
subvenir aux besoins de sa maman
gravement malade
disons plus tard c'est à cilaos qu'il
travaille comme contremaître sur le
chantier du grand hôtel l'histoire
d'amour avec le cirque commence
mais c'est à saint louis que le jeune
ouvrier devenu entrepreneur se lance
dans la politique
en 1952 alors qu'il est conseiller
municipal et général de la commune il
épouse une jeune dionysienne la première
institutrice de cilaos
lorsque cilaos devient une commune en
1965 il en devient le maire et le
conseiller général il le restera pendant
22 ans avec peu d'opposants
ni à droite ni à gauche irénée accot n'a
qu'une idée en tête faire de cilaos la
capitale du tourisme vert de la réunion
ou opio toi à l'établissement thermal
fonctionnel répondant aux normes
leurs embouts et développe donc le
thermalisme il fait la promotion de la
broderie du vin de la randonnée il n'en
n'oublie pas pour autant ses administrés
construisant des écoles des routes et
des équipements sportifs
cependant son oeuvre s'interrompra net
le 7 octobre 1987 victime d'une attaque
cardiaque
il meurt le 11 novembre de cette même
année